there was a baby in the crowd like a
family brought a baby in my crowd I'm
doing stand up and all of a sudden I
hear
and I'm like oh [__] and obviously I had
to say hey is there a baby in here and
there was should you or should you not
bring a baby to a show I'm not even
doing that argument okay uh the here's
the thing I want to know how the [__]
did they get it in
sup
sup security sup
do you know what I'm saying like you
don't actually have to get a babysitter
and [__] did the baby need a ticket
did the baby
it was the most confusing thing and I
actually don't even know if I have much
to say about it but like I really I
really wish I could ask them more about
it
she's like well listen you can have
hey is it a baby here
[Applause]
it's like I try to ignore it but but
there's a baby here so you can't exactly
kick a baby out you know
you you come with me
you're gonna have to get an Uber
there's blippi sold out for some [__]
know that [__] oh come on guys that
guy no way my son's not watching that
that's a weird [__] guy
hey guys I'm blippi
come on come on let's learn about
[__] mammals
not from you bro what was the baby's
favorite joke so far
oh
like they don't stop you if you have a
baby
and just walk into a place where they're
like five babies dressed in a [__]
trench coat
one
five two one ticket please
thank you
why are you crying I don't know my
[__] baby
I think I'm hurt or something I don't
know
who's pissed whoever's the shoulders
whoever's the shoulders pissed thank you
how do you notice the shoulders well hey
hey guy who's the head are you wet no
is everyone else wet
yes we're all wet
it was whoever sold us
just a wet spot right here sorry I'm
lactating
I don't even know what I was talking
about therapy
[Applause]
hahaha